george bush and dick cheney started new
wars in iraq and afghanistan
obama started new wars in in libya and
and yemen
what new wars did donald trump start you
go down the list
and when you look at things like the
destruction of iraq or the
implementation of a torture regime
what has donald trump done that even
remotely compares in terms of moral evil
to any of that nothing and yet you know
we're supposed to treat george bush and
barack obama like
morally upstanding statesman and donald
trump like the literal reincarnation of
hitler
there's no journalist who is more
relentlessly iconoclastic than glenn
greenwald who won the 2014
pulitzer prize for his reporting on the
snowden revelations
though unapologetically progressive the
53 year old former lawyer
never shrinks from fighting with the
left a week before the 2020 election he
quit the intercept
the online news site he co-founded in
2014
because by his account it refused to run
a story unless he removed all
sections critical of joe biden
denouncing what he called the
pathology's illiberalism and repressive
mentality that led to him being
censored by his own media outlet
greenwald railed that these are the
viruses that have contaminated virtually
every mainstream center-left political
organization
academic institution and newsroom like a
growing number of refugees from more
traditional news organizations greenwall
took his talents to sub stack a platform
for independent content creators to earn
revenue directly from their audiences he
wasted no time
lobbing grenades posting stories and
videos with titles like no matter the
liberal metric chosen the bush cheney
administration was far
worse than trump and the three greatest
dangers of biden harris
militarism corporatism and censorship
all fueled by indifference
i spoke with greenwald via zoom at his
house in brazil where he lives with his
husband
two children and numerous dogs among
other topics we discussed what he sees
as a generational fight
playing out in newsrooms the challenge
identity politics poses to free
expression
and whether a coalition of libertarians
and progressives can effectively push
non-interventionist foreign policy
lifestyle liberation
and an end to corporate subsidies during
the presidency
of joe biden glenn greenwald thanks for
talking to reason
always happy to be with reason good to
see you nick yes uh you know
uh let's see uh let's start with um
you're leaving the intercept which you
announced uh less than a month ago as
we're talking
and in uh the piece that you wrote
explaining
why you left this you know amazing
uh publication platform that you helped
start
only a few years ago you said that you
were witnessing or experiencing the same
trends of repression
censorship and ideological homogeneity
plaguing the national press um so what
happened
well you some of you may recall that
when
i created the intercept with jewel with
laura poitras and jeremy scale
it was at the height of the snowden
story back in 2013
i was at the guardian at the time and
i had received a lot of support
institutionally and editorially from the
guardian but i began noticing
as i worked with other media outlets to
report that story a lot of internal
obstacles that i thought were quite
difficult to overcome
in terms of doing the kind of reporting
not just with that story but
in general i thought needed to be done
and
because laura and i had a lot of
visibility with that story and and
jeremy had done
a lot of um high
visibility reporting of his own
including having produced a film about
obama's war on terror called dirty words
that had received an oscar nomination
we had a lot of leverage to create a new
media outlet and we obviously didn't do
that
given that we all had very good
platforms at the time
to replicate what was already being done
we only left the places we were at which
were very secure because we thought we
could do something different in
journalism and one of the
principal visions we had was
that we thought the model for how
journalism is often conducted inside
corporate media outlets which is this
hierarchical top-down structure
where editors impose not necessarily an
ideology as much as a kind of tone
so they flatten out the vibrancy and
personality and voice in journalism
make everything sound the same make
everything adhere to these very rigid
rules of how you can express yourself
what kind of views can be heard with
stifling journalism it was making it not
just ineffective but actually quite
boring and the idea was
it's going to be a journalism-led media
outlet where editors are there to help
you when you need it to
kind of kick the tires on stories to
make sure that things are factually
sound
but they're not the bosses they're not
the people you have to overcome who
decide whether you can be heard or not
um and i had written into my contract
just like i did at the guardian and
salon
that except in very rare cases where
there was like very complex original
reporting like in the snowden story the
brazil
reporting we did last year that i would
just publish directly to the internet
with no editorial intervention
and that was the model we thought we
were building that i thought i was
building i never thought it had anything
to do with
ideological dogma um and certainly never
fealty to any political party i was a
vehement obama critic at the time as you
know
and before that was a vehement critic of
george bush and dick cheney so it was
always that we called ourselves
adversarial
because we were going to be adversarial
to political power not
subservient to it and so i felt as
though we had gotten off course for
a few years now by becoming more and
more linked with the democratic party
particularly
in the age of trump where we had become
not so much a journalistic outlet but
more
uh activist outlet designed not to
reporting the truth no matter who it
aggrandizes or angers but
serving the interests of the democratic
party and more so undermining the
interest of donald trump which
ultimately became the same thing
and it all culminated in they're
essentially telling me that i couldn't
publish my own story at an internet at
a news outlet that was built on my name
along with jeremy and laura's but
certainly traded on my reputation traded
on my accomplishments that a lot of
people
associated with me and it was a huge
irony and
being stifled in saying what i wanted to
say obviously was something i could
never accept that my readers would want
me to
and so i left reading the story that you
published eventually
uh and whatnot you know and it had you
know some of that hunter biden special
sauce on it which is
uh i don't know if you've ever uh eaten
that popeye's chicken but they have a
thing called
cajun sparkle which is just msg on
steroids and it makes everything very
flavorful
the story that you wrote was uh you know
it was critical of joe biden and of
hunter biden and a variety of things but
it doesn't seem like
that should be something that they would
be hell-bent on stopping was it just
they were afraid
this might help trump win his second
term
yeah i mean that's one of the ironies
right is that i wasn't doing original
reporting i actually did try and get
some of those emails so that i could
report on them but wasn't able to
so it was really just kind of my own
analysis of what these emails showed and
also
of the press's behavior in not just
avoiding reporting on them but creating
this kind of
edifice of rationale rationalization to
avoid talking about them that i thought
was journalistically corrupt
so what i wrote was both an indictment
of
media behavior that was designed to
protect joe biden and then also my
analysis of what i thought these emails
showed so it was really like more of an
opinion piece than
say original reporting which is exactly
why it was so strange that they were
interested in uh editing it
um especially to that extent because
those are exactly the kinds of articles
i've written
a thousand times that have never touched
an editor let alone
had that kind of editorial scrutiny i
don't think
anyone thought that article was going to
sway the election it wasn't that big of
a deal
what that article there
yeah go ahead oh so i mean it's it's
really just that the
your um you know your editors or or
other staffers however the kind of
hierarchy or hetarchy works there
they just didn't want to be part of they
didn't want that kind of story coming
out at that time because
they were pulling for biden i mean is
that essentially what you're saying
i i i i
i think it's actually in some ways worse
than that i mean if it were the case
that i had this huge bombshell
that could have actually swayed the
election for trump
i almost would have understood more what
they were doing
i would have been horrified and
disgusted and would have left anyway
but at least it would have made sense i
think what
the reason why it bothered me even more
would no one thought that article was
going to sway the election what they
were worried about
was that in 2016 we did do a lot of
reporting because we're journalists and
not
activists for the dnc on the emails from
john podesta
and and and the dnc that revealed a lot
of high-level corruption
by the dnc a lot of uh things about
hillary clinton the public had a right
to know
and they spent four years being accused
of having helped trump win by virtue of
doing this reporting
what they were petrified of was that
their friends
their colleagues journalists and other
outlets that they value
like on the liberal left we're gonna say
oh look the intercept's doing this again
so if trump won they were they didn't
want to be
go to dinner parties and have people say
why did you help trump win by publishing
this before the election
and even if he didn't win they didn't
want to be accused of that so no one
thought that my article was going to
sway the election they thought that it
was going to change
the perception of them and they
intercept in the eyes of their friends
and the people whose opinions they value
in the media and that's why it was
actually
even more repellent to me that that was
that the trivial concerns that they had
about what people would think of them
is that you know in a lot of ways is
that the worst thing uh trump has done
um is that he's taken people who
you know do not call themselves
democrats uh you know they're these
these
none of the people you work with are you
know thinking hillary clinton was god's
gift to
uh the universe or joe biden but they
become
so anti-trump that they are you know
they're willing to be kind of
repressive in a way you know that they
really shouldn't
recognize themselves as doing that
yeah so i think there's a few things
going on there i think
you know what happened was
media left-wing media liberal media in
particular was dying
before trump ironically he was their
godsend most of the hosts on msnbc who
are now big stars and making millions of
dollars a year
were on the verge of being fired nobody
was watching their shitty shows
because who wanted who's going to tune
in to hear
you know people giving fluff interviews
to like amy klobuchar and talking about
how lovely obama is and how mean mitch
mcconnell is it just doesn't get
anyone's juices flowing
trump saved them he saved them he made
the new york times this incredibly
profitable institution
and so what they learned was the more
they elevated the fear levels of people
not just about trump but about his
movement
that he wasn't just somebody with bad
policies but he was
actually hitler he was a fascist
dictator with a fascist white
supremacist movement of domestic
terrorists
who weren't seeking to implement bad
policy but who were actually
on the verge of ending american
democracy as we know it
and that he had to be stopped at all
costs once you
implement that narrative first of all a
lot of them started believing it because
they just kept
through repetition hearing it saying it
all their friends said it so some of
them it was just true conviction they
really did believe they were
that they were living under the rule of
hitler and that therefore anything you'd
have to do
no matter how unethical no matter how
much of a departure it is from your
professional ethics is justified or not
even just justified but
an imperative but a lot of them
you know knew that they were benefiting
because the more you
beat that drum if trump is hitler we're
fighting trump or
you feel good about yourself it gives
you purpose people applaud you your
social media following grows
and then even the ones who kind of never
bought into that
are still immersed in a liberal culture
that believes that
and when media jobs are disappearing and
you know layoffs are happening in
journalism by the millions
or the uh where the thousands rather the
last thing you want to do is stick your
head up and say something that might
make you unpopular among media
colleagues
on whom you might have to rely for your
job in the future
and it fosters this conformity this
homogeneity this fear of saying anything
off-key
and i think that is what explains a lot
of media behavior over the last four
years
you know uh a recent piece that you read
at sub stack
uh is uh uh talks about how trump cheney
uh say let me get the actual headline uh
no matter what
no matter the liberal metric chosen the
bush cheney administration
was far worse than trump and in that
story you also point out in various ways
how the obama administration
was worse than trump can you quickly
sketch
why you know suddenly out of the last
three presidents
trump seems in at least some significant
ways to be the least
horrible president that we've had
yeah i think that's probably true and
and it's not because he's necessarily
the least horrible person
a lot of times a president can be bad
but doesn't get anything done that's bad
because they're incompetent and lazy
which i think is true of trump
or because they just trigger so much
anger and resentment and resistance
that it prevents them from actually
doing anything which i also think is
true whereas under bush and obama
you know i started writing about about
politics because i thought the media was
so
dormant and complacent about these
radical
assaults on civil liberties under bush
and cheney taking place
during the war on terror and then under
obama they went to sleep even further
right they got like hypnotized
thinking that he was a noble and
benevolent leader
and just i'll give you just one example
which is press freedom
under obama as i'm sure you know
the espionage act of 1917 one of the
most pernicious laws we have on our
books it was enacted underwood rules and
it was designed to criminalize
dissent from u.s participation in world
war one
was invoked against whistleblowers and
sources like edward snowden or chelsea
manning and
a dozen others more under obama
than every other prior president
combined
combined in fact it was ended up being
three times more prosecution than the
espionage act for our sources as
journalists
than all previous presidents including
nixon or eisenhower
or whoever you want to pick and the
press said almost nothing there were a
couple people in the press you know
saying that suddenly trump gets in
and the washington post changes its
motto
to democracy dies in darkness
essentially saying
press freedom is under assault jim
acosta writes a best-selling book
with some pompous self-glorifying title
like
danger you know reporting in the era of
trump what the [ __ ] ever happened to jim
acosta that constitutes an assault on
press freedom
the worst thing trump ever did to any of
them was like
say mean things about them in tweets
those aren't assaults on press freedom i
was threatened by the obama
administration with prison when i was
doing the snowden reporting i was
criminally indicted by the bolsonaro
government
at the beginning of this year for the
reporting i did in brazil those are
attacks on press freedom
saying jim acosta is an idiot and
tweeting something insulting about wolf
blitzer
isn't um so you know you kind of go
through those metrics like
obviously george bush and dick cheney
started new wars in iraq and afghanistan
obama started new wars in in libya and
and yemen
what new wars did did donald trump start
he escalated bombing campaigns which he
inherited in a pretty grotesque way but
he didn't start a new war so you go down
the list
and when you look at things like the
destruction of iraq or the
implementation of a torture regime
what has donald trump done that even
remotely compares in terms of moral evil
to any of that nothing and yet you know
we're supposed to treat george bush and
dick and and and barack obama like
morally upstanding statesman and donald
trump like the literal reincarnation of
hitler
so did you vote for donald trump in the
election
i don't know if you voted in the
presidential election but
who did you vote for if you did
yeah i didn't vote because i just it's
ironic because i do
i that's the one like old journalism
trope that i agree with which is that
like if you vote you kind of
psychologically become too connected to
a
politician i prefer to just keep my
distance um
yeah um you know um
it's it's really interesting to think
about
uh the way you're talking about this
homogeneity and this you know this kind
of group think is coming
in the old days of kind of legacy media
you would that the story would always be
that the editorial side was super
independent and that the managing editor
and the editor-in-chief was fighting for
press freedom
and it was the business side that would
be leaning on them to say like don't
investigate this story because they
advertise in our paper
or you know something like ibsen's uh
enemy of the people where
you know uh by pursuing truth you would
undermine
people's livelihood or or the ability of
a nation to
you know kind of defend its borders when
did it become
this you know world where it's it's not
business pressure i mean
you you are a critic of what you call
corporate media
which has you know has a lot of money
interests that kind of change things
but this is something different right
this is actually
people internalizing group think who are
all on the editorial side of things
yeah exactly i mean like you know the
intercept for example one of the things
we thought we had done to insulate
ourselves and these kind of pressures
was we didn't have a whole school of
investors we had one
thunder who was a billionaire the
founder of ebay pierre meteor
but he treated us and we created
ourselves as a 501c3
which was a non-profit so that we
wouldn't have any pressure to produce
revenue we didn't have to produce click
bait
we could send off young reporters for
months and say don't worry about
the news cycle just go and investigate
this we didn't have subscribers
he just gave us his money promised to
stay out of our editorial business
and kept that promise for seven years so
we had no interference at all it was
like the dream right
from like the exactly the kind of
business influences that would typically
contaminate a newsroom what contaminated
it was exactly as you
astutely observed which was the kind of
news editorial side that had
traditionally defended
journalistic freedom i think two things
are happening here
number one is it is true that in the age
of
the internet media outlets
and news outlets and news organizations
are
are struggling financially how do you
survive when
local papers can't do ads anymore
because craigslist offers them for free
all the things we know about you know
there's been barely a digital media
outlet even the ones that looked like
they were going to thrive like
huffington post or buzzfeed
that haven't laid off you know thousands
of hundreds or
thousands of people in the last couple
of years
um so people are looking around for a
model that works
and one of the only models that works
is the one that fox news pioneered
so successfully which is to say we're
only going to talk to this audience
of this particular partisan and
ideological persuasion and we're going
to feed them
constant high excitement
content that's going to keep them
watching you know in the 1990s they just
the hatred levels generated for the
clintons
over vince foster and drug running and
mena and all of that
to say nothing of the lewinsky scandal
was so successful right and the drudge
report
and and culture and rush limbaugh that
became a really discussed model in the
new york times cnn and msnbc were all
looking at this and saying
we don't have the success what are we
going to do and so they started thinking
well we should do it with the other side
and they do there was a
puse a pew survey from two months ago
that i found amazing
it asked people name your number one
source of news your principal the
principal place you go to get news
and so people who said fox news 94 of
them are republicans as you would expect
people said msnbc said
95 of them are democrats as you would
expect people who said the new york
times
nick 91 91 are democrats
the new york times was only talking to
democrats
npr 88 cnn 79
these outlets have an audience that
don't want to hear the other side they
i you know when when russiagate becomes
became
so important to these media outlets
profitability i used to go on msnbc all
the time
matt taibbi did too jeremy scale did too
they stopped inviting assad they didn't
want any dissent they didn't want any
dissent or questioning
because they knew that their audience
didn't want to hear it so when you and
at least fox news like tucker would put
on
adam's chef he liked having those
debates the other outlets didn't want it
and so they've just turned themselves
into these silos of homogeneous opinion
and you know if you want to keep your
job at msnbc
or the new york times those pieties are
ones you better affirm and never
question
and so it just becomes financial motive
but then it starts to shape the culture
yeah it's interesting too uh the new
york times now gets more money from what
i understand
they get more revenue from subscriptions
than they do from advertising so the
the line directly to an audience that is
demanding something or expecting
something seems even clearer
that it might even be at a place like
fox news
right and also i think the other
interesting thing is
that you know um
for a long time there was you know in
like say the 80s
the republicans were kind of the party
of wall street and corporate america
right it was reagan
wanting to cut the corporate taxes and
the democrats at the party reunions
so if you were a corporate media outlet
that relied on
corporate america for your revenue which
they did you would
there'd be an argument that you would
want to appease the republican agenda
because that was what corporate america
wanted
right that has all changed now if you
look at who wall street gives their
money to who silicon valley gives their
money to it's the democratic party they
became a corporatized party
so there's no longer this difference in
agendas even either between
corporate uh advertisers
and the democratic and liberal politics
i don't mean left-wing politics i mean
establishment liberalism
raytheon and boeing and you know
facebook and and and goldman sachs and
citibank
love the liberal agenda meaning like
the chuck schumer joe biden barack obama
agenda
so even there there's been this
convergence that's just that is the new
coalition of power
in the united states yeah so you have
migrated to sub stack which i suspect
most of the people watching this have
some understanding of but it's
it's a site or a service that allows
creators to put up whatever they want
and then to charge money for it
you charge 50 a year five dollars a
month for
what you produce there um a lot of other
people are doing the
same thing or have done the same thing
at sub stack or or sites like patreon
which is
another kind of creator focus site i'm
thinking of people like
uh all over the pla ideological spectrum
andrew sullivan matt taibi
mataglisius uh late of vox people like
katie herzog and jesse single
um how is is this the future um
or is this scalable this type of thing
where
journalists who have um you know kind of
trouble
fitting in even at places that they
started
can go there and support themselves and
produce varied
heterodox content or is this mostly it's
people like you
who have a massive following already as
well as a reputation
where you can go and kind of get a
direct stream of revenue
so i think it's a grounds for being
optimistic in the sense that it isn't
just people like me
you know like andrew sullivan has talked
openly about the fact that he's making
more money now
after being on substance for i think
three or four months
and he's made in his entire career
working at i mean
andrew has you know is one of the most
successful journalists of the last
several decades
he's worked everywhere time magazine at
its peak
the atlantic and you know new york
magazine new york
everywhere um matt tybee was at rolling
stone like one of the most coveted gigs
you know being a
matt is making more money than he's ever
dreamed he would make
and it's not just us it's you know your
colleague matt welch has a
uh podcast called fifth column that i've
been on
twice now that's incredibly interesting
i listen to it all the time i pay for it
so and and it's discovered and it's
letting new voices be discovered too and
it's amazing these platforms say
what silicon valley started off saying
which was
we're not a publishing company like
substack says we're not
approving or disapproving the content
that goes out on our platform
we're just providing a service that
allows business people to come and
monetize their journalism or their
writing
so in that sense it is good but there's
two centers in which
we need to be very uh con restrained
about our enthusiasm
one is that um whatever
independent entity arises that gives
journalists freedom and begins
to compete with corporate media outlets
they turn their guns on it
but the main people don't realize this
the main reason
facebook and google and twitter so
actively censor now
isn't because they wanted to they don't
want to they never wanted to they wanted
to tell that story
that sub stack is telling that at t
tells right which is like
look we're just a neutral platform we
don't pick and choose who gets to speak
and nobody expects like if milo
yiannopoulos calls alex jones on a t and
does a conference call that at d
intervenes and cuts off their service
because people accept no at t is a
content neutral service
that's what facebook and twitter wanted
to be they had to stop doing that they
had to start censoring first alex jones
and milo yiannopoulos and increasingly
more and more voices because journalists
at cnn and nbc in the new york times
demanded they do so
you know turning their huge megaphones
and saying
look at the extremists and the
hatefulness these platforms are
giving voice to and they're going to do
the same thing to sub stack and patreon
it's just a question of time
so that's number one is those places are
going to start to experience a lot of
those same pressures to start kicking
people off
who the new york times and cnn
successfully demonizes as two extremists
but i think the other important thing is
that it's great i love being on
substance
it's like a throwback to the days of how
i started right when i was just a
blogger
i wrote my own column i only was
answerable to my audience
you know i'm making a lot of money so i
can have other journalists working with
me which i do but still it's basically
the same model
but in order to really have a big impact
to like be a
competitor in the discourse to the new
york times or msnbc or the washington
post
to do real investigations like the
snowden story
or what wikileaks does or the brazil
investigation
you need a newsroom you need like a team
of journalists and editors and
and and lawyers and technologists
so you know i talked about the fact that
before i left the intercept so
precipitously because of that censorship
i had already been exploring the
possibility of again
kind of creating a new media outlet
based on this model that would bring
everybody together who believes in this
vision
of free and open discourse of opposing
this new
establishment concentration of power
um so i'm still looking to do that but i
think sub stack and patreon are great
and that they at least do give people an
opportunity to have a place where they
can go free of those constraints
um so you you are not actively working i
was going to ask you in your
resignation letter you kind of hinted at
you were looking to get
to leave uh and start something new
anyway but you haven't actually started
doing that yet
well we've started just i mean we've you
know been speaking to people who we
think
it would be interesting to work with us
we talked to potential
financers we're just in that stage where
of development though
um you know part of uh so you sketch out
a kind of economically driven
reason for the the homogenation
uh homogenization of of journalism
it's partly you know people at cnn and
the new york times
they want to get rid of people who are
going to
you know kind of get uh you know get
more eyeballs than they do
in another way some of the work that
you've been doing recently talks about
it in starkly ideological terms and you
recently wrote a piece
discussing kind of uh trends at the aclu
under anthony romero who's been the
executive director for 20 years
um and uh your kind of interactions or
your sense of
recent
series of tweets or actions by chase
strangio who is the aclu deputy director
for transgender justice um who had
represented chelsea manning
uh back in the day who you have a lot of
respect for as a
as a lawyer but who had recently uh come
out
and talked about stopping the
circulation of a book
uh by abigail schreier called
irreversible damage which questioned
certain elements of early uh adolescent
or pre-adolescent
transgender uh kind of uh operations and
whatnot
but you you talk about the aclu as a
group that is moving from
a kind of free speech absolutism uh
which you grew up on in which you kind
of
uh really uh idolize to
an organization now that is starting to
say well ideology or or
you know certain certain positions
are more important than the kind of
value neutral concept of free speech
can you talk a little bit about what's
going on at the aclu and how that kind
of
reflects or refracts larger ideological
questions particularly on the left it
seems the right is its own problem and
they've never been particularly
interested in adoradox ideas i think
but on the left we're seeing a an
ideological narrowing of discussion
yeah you know in one sense what's
happening at the aclu
is happening it's the same thing
happening on every college campus
practically in corporate workplaces and
also in newsrooms which is there's this
it largely breaks down on generational
lines although not
completely of course but largely in
which this kind of younger millennial
set who are now not that young anymore
they're
in their mid-30s or or or older and
starting to
assume managerial authority within these
institutions grew up believing that free
speech is not an absolute value and that
it needs to give way in
all kinds of instances where more
important political agenda items and
more important political values are in
conflict with it as they understand it
by which they mean
ideas and arguments that might endanger
marginalized people by making them
uncomfortable
or that might lead to the implementation
of
harmful policies by convincing people to
support them
are not ideas that should be heard
they're ideas that should be suppressed
in the name of these greater
political values and it's something at
the intercept that i talked about in
that article
we heard explicitly there's a diversity
committee that's part of the intercept
union the
intercept union like most newsroom
unions they talk almost nothing about
the typical things unions used to talk
about that made them so worthwhile like
more weight better wages
more days off you know holidays pensions
all of that they
they have no interest in any of that
they talk only about how to control
the the content of their colleagues
speech in the name of human resources
and union diversity issues
and there was a letter that they wrote
that leaked to the new york times in
which they said yes okay fine free
speech is important we know the founders
of the intercept
are free speech absolutist or radicals
but it has to give way when it's in
conflict with our anti-racism
agenda and i didn't know that a news
organization had an anti-racism agenda i
knew
we wanted to make sure we weren't a
racist news organization but i didn't
know we were
that was one of our primary purposes it
was news to me so this
conflict is happening everywhere right
like barry weiss when she up the new
york times described
uh the newsroom fight that she kind of
live tweeted
as being these like millennial editor
you know young editors and reporters
saying how dare you publish this tom
cotton op-ed and the
older reporters are saying that's like
what we do we're a newspaper we air
ideas that powerful people
are so that so this this conflict that
is in the aclu in one sense is a common
one
the problem is the aclu is a singular
organization in the sense that unlike
all these other institutions that i just
referenced
they really were the only game in town
when it came to defending an absolutist
framework of free speech they didn't
give a [ __ ] what other values were at
play they
these jewish lawyers in the 1970s
represented
the actual nazis who were wearing
swastika armbands
and their right to march down the
streets of skokie illinois where
holocaust survivors a large population
of holocaust survivors were that's how
radical they were
and not just free speech but also due
process the idea that you cannot no
matter how
you know odious a person's crime is that
they're accused of assume their guilt
without giving them full due process
and i know a lot of people at the aclu
i've worked with the aclu for years i
have a lot of friends there who are who
are lawyers and
they are now being driven by these same
conflicts in part because
they part of it is financial that after
trump
these a huge number of liberals who
thought the aclu was just a liberal
organization gave
millions and millions of dollars not in
the name of civil liberties but in the
name of stopping trump which sometimes
converged and sometimes didn't
so they started becoming an overtly
political organization i remember
one time i was so shocked paris had
adopted a law
criminalizing catcalling on the street
whistling at women when they walked by
which that's not a good thing to do
but like it was it was a crime now with
this
and the someone on the aclu twitter feed
celebrated the criminalization of speech
in the name of these liberal values
another time they condemned betsy devos
who wanted to expand the amount of due
process
people are entitled to when they're
accused of sexual assault the aclu is
against
due process they want lesser due process
in the name of
sexual assault so when strange when when
when
when uh chase uh strangio
came out and said once you know abigail
wrote her article on colette about how
amazon and other publishing houses have
been bullied out of publishing her book
chase said um stopping circulation of
this book is 100 because i'm willing to
devote it
it was now not just the aclu defending
the diminution of due process or
the criminalization of speech but
suppression of books
and and like chase is not some low-level
aclu lawyer he was
just named to the time 100 list of the
world's most influential people that's
how
significant of a personage he has become
largely because of his work on trans
issues he is a trans lawyer himself
and so it was horrifying you know it's
one thing
for the new york times to get woke and
not allow tom cotton's
op-eds or for college you know campuses
to dis-invite
conte but for the aclu to openly cheer
at least a lawyer there
the suppression of a book was
horrifying to me as someone who you know
for whom the aclu is extremely important
where where do you think that um
generational shift like what drives it
you know part of it is probably um
you know it is just generational that
every generation kind of rebels or
pushes away from
the older generation um but
you know what what happened or what is
happening in american society because it
does seem to be
you know an absolute trend that the or
or it's a fact that
younger people do not treat uh the idea
of uh
free speech as an absolute right it just
does not exist in their catechism or
their vision of the world
what happened
yeah you know it's funny i mean i have
to say you know when some pundits like
jonathan chait were obsessed with these
college
campus controversies i really didn't pay
much attention because i just
thought okay that you know i did a lot i
had a lot of views in college and i grew
out of them
um you know i wasn't interested in like
chiding 21 year old sophomores at
overland
you know i didn't think that was like a
very important
power center to go and denounce and
confront the way jonathan
and others were doing kind of
obsessively i have to say you know they
turn out to be right
in the sense that it did they didn't
grow out of it
they they brought it with them to their
workplaces and
and they've never grown out of it and as
i said these millennials aren't 20
anymore they're 35 and 40
and they still haven't grown out of it
and so when you learn
in childhood that if you
have something unpleasant you run to
mommy and daddy who protects you from it
which is kind of a new kind of parenting
and then you go off to college
and you have you know deans in your
dorms and high school and
college administrators who like if you
hear something in class that upsets you
they don't tell you to go [ __ ] off and
go
argue against it they like coddle you
and tell you that
you have a right to be safe from those
things and then you get to
your workplace and you hear colleagues
saying things that upset you because you
think they're
terrible or destructive or harmful or
wrong and instead of engaging them
and writing about them the way
journalists used to do right like
go read the nation magazine like when
chris hitchens was there with
you know um eric alterman and all those
people they had a vicious argument so
it's like so vibrant you know that
intellectual
debate they run to human resources they
turn it into an hr complaint
and you know i think the best book that
i've read is one that i'm sure is known
to a lot of
your audience which is cuddling of the
american mind by jonathan hate
and um who's his co-author at fire
greg look off exactly which i think
explains
this so in fact it explained it so well
that i actually changed
not just how i viewed these issues as a
journalist who writes about free speech
but also even as a parent
you know where my instinct is like if my
kids
have something that's upsetting them
your instinct is to go protect them and
then i realize like no sometimes you
have to just let them
kind of like experience the unpleasant
thing and learn those skills about how
to navigate it
i don't mean you let them like suffer
physically if they hurt themselves i
just mean that you can't
protect them from every unpleasant thing
in the world because you actually aren't
doing them very good you're going to
turn them into
little woke warriors who demand that hr
fire anyone who has an opinion different
than they do
you know uh this leads into uh i i want
to ask you a question about a
fascinating story you read i i guess
this was one of your last pieces or
or it was at the intercept but you
discussed um
you were working on a documentary film
about martina navratilova the
you know fantastic openly lesbian
women's tennis champion who defected
from
communist czechoslovakia to america just
totally
uh you know re redefined tennis
in general especially women's tennis um
and you tell a story you were going to
be do a documentary about her because
she was one of your heroes growing up
um what happened to derail that uh
project yeah you know it's funny i mean
she was one of she was like what i would
say she was like
my one or you know top one or two
childhood heroes like along with like
daniel ellsberg and like
woodward and bernstein like the obvious
ones and so in adulthood when i started
doing the snowden story
um she started following me on twitter
and then she started like
tweeting at me you know i like i'm a
journalist so i've talked to a lot of
famous people
in my work i don't give the slightest
[ __ ] but like when she first time i ever
talked to martina i called my friends i
could barely breathe i was like a 12
year old who would like
you know some like girl band member had
like touched me and i was like you know
over the moon and it was
and then my friend started saying like
god why is she so
like why was she so important to you and
i started thinking about it you know it
was like an interesting question there's
the obvious
answer that i grew up as a gay kid she
was one of the only few openly gay
people in the world at the time who was
you know famous and and so that gave me
kind of an end to
someone identify with but i realized
that it was actually like she was just a
transgressive
figure as you say she left communist
czechoslovakia at the age of 18
dangerously she left her family behind
she
couldn't go back to them and see them
for like 15 years because she wanted the
freedom of the united states
um she was openly gay she hired a trans
woman as her coach in 1984 and like
would travel around the world with her
put her on network news
um martino was a huge sports star
so i wanted to make a documentary kind
of exploring and she also became like an
outspoken defender of like
the rights of dissidents you know like
after 9 11 she was one and the weeks
after 9 11 she was one of the few people
willing to say she thought george bush
was turning the united states into
repressive communism
um so she's always been this kind of
transgressive figure so i wanted to
explore what it was about her that
made her so important in my life it was
kind of be that kind of it wasn't like a
bio about her it was more of
an examination about our interaction and
what happened was
um i had hired this uh we found this
director
the first director was kim pearce who
had directed this film called boys don't
cry
that won an oscar in 1995 for hillary
swank and it was about a
trans boy who was murdered so it was
like a pioneering film and during the
course of my working with kim pearce
she told me the story of how she
couldn't go to college campuses one in
particular
because trans people protested her
even though she identifies as non-binary
and did this groundbreaking film on the
grounds
she had hired a cis woman hillary swank
to play this role
um i just found that fascinating but
then that didn't work out we had some
artistic differences about how to do the
film so my second
uh director was another trans woman a
trans woman kimberly reed who had done
two great films
and in the course of our starting
development martina had seen a picture
on the internet of a trans
woman cyclist who has never had gender
reassignment surgery so she has a penis
and testicles
no breasts holding a gold medal and she
was like
ha you know this hovering figure over
two cis women who had like won the
bronze and silver would train to cycle
us their whole lives this trans woman
started cycling very late in life
and martina who is one of the main
reasons like with billie jean king and
chris everett why there is such a thing
as professional women's
sports why women female athletes can
earn a very good living
was like wait a minute all you have to
do if you're
a man and you want to compete as a woman
and take our money and trophies is just
say that you're
a woman and you get to like compete
against us and
take all our money and trophies and then
you know you just go back and you live
as a man you impregnate a woman and
for that the trans community was like
they they they assembled and hatred
against her and said
you're a hateful bigot martina
navratilova like one of the
lgbt pioneers she was on every board of
every lgbt sports board
so she apologized she said um you know
what i
spoke without being informed i'm gonna
go off and inform myself
but it wasn't enough they just kept like
at it and kept demonizing her and
calling her a bigot and then finally she
just came back with an article in the
london times about a month later saying
i've studied this and i've concluded
that if you go through puberty as a man
it doesn't matter how many hormones you
take
it will never be fair for trans women to
compete on equal footing
with cis women in professional athletes
um
it's a form of cheating for them to do
it and it just made martina radioactive
um the director who i was working with
felt like she would have had to have
made the whole film about this and it
just
you know the reality is what i always
loved about martino wasn't that she was
this great left-wing
figure it was that she was defiant and
transgressive of pieties
which is the same thing that led her to
do that um
but it just made the film kind of
radically different and too difficult to
make and we kind of had to just give up
on it
i am sorry to hear that as uh some of
our listeners may know
martina navratilova was one of reason's
35 heroes of freedom
uh when we were celebrating our 35th
anniversary for most of the reasons you
pointed out she's a
you know regardless of her politics or
her ideology she's an individualist who
commanded the who commands the world's
attention because she really
you know lives her life um let's talk
about
the uh the biden harris
uh administration um you have recently
written
the three greatest threats of of a biden
harris administration are militarism
corporatism and censorship
let's work through those uh one at a
time
or you know because one of the things
that's interesting about your work
particularly to a libertarian audience
is you know during the russiagate stuff
you were one of the few people who was
not
just kind of uh reliving the cold war
and assuming any any all you have to do
is mention
russia and then people's critical
thinking skills disappear and whatnot
um what is what's the threat of
militarism from joe biden
well so biden you know himself is a very
uh veteran politician right he has
almost 50 years in public life we know
what his ideology is
and he was always a centrist
democrat um and you know the great
war and peace question of our time of
the last generation was obviously the
war in iraq
and at the time when it was being
debated in 2002 he was the chairman of
the foreign relations committee which
was the most important
senate committee and senate positioned
to occupy
and played a critical role in advocating
the
bush cheney case for invading iraq that
sodom hussein had nuclear weapons
that the intelligence was solid that we
couldn't tolerate a world in which
the iraqis had uh weapons of mass
destruction
all of that and you know more than
hillary clinton who was saying the same
thing more than john kerry was saying
the same thing it was really biden who
played the key role in getting the
senate behind
bush and cheney and ultimately you know
passing
the authorization to use military force
in october 2002 by a vote of you know 66
to 33 or whatever it was
and then just beyond that he's always
you know been i mean he was opposed to
the
first gulf war which is one of the
things in this column but he was a big
proponent as well of the intervention in
yugoslavia during the clinton war
during the clinton era and then during
the by the obama administration
you know you look at the obama
administration and the participation in
the regime change war in libya which
turned into an
utter and complete disaster um as well
as the
efforts to help the saudis bomb the
living [ __ ] out of yemen and create the
world's worst
humanitarian catastrophe in yemen where
millions of people are
food insecure and on the brink of
starvation
it is a ideology of militarism without
question they
have attacked trump from the right
repeatedly from the right
repeatedly that he's not belligerent
enough toward moscow
that he doesn't give our that he didn't
topple bashar al-assad
um you know susan rice and ben rhodes
and samantha power and michelle forney
all the people who are going to be
exercising
real authority when it comes to national
security are all
war mongers it's the reason why bill
crystal and david frum
and jennifer rubin and those lincoln
project goons
were so behind them it wasn't just
because they hated trump
it was because there's a really
interesting article nick from 2014
before anyone had any inkling that there
would be a president trump
in the new york times that talked about
how neocons were migrating back to the
democratic party with the expectation
that hillary was going to be president
because within the republican party they
were starting to be obvious strains with
the wrong the success of the ron paul
candidacy
and before that pat buchanan of this
kind of isolationist whatever you want
to call it
non-interventionist strain within the
republican party
it was already there when george bush
ran remember he ran
condemning what he called the
insufficiently humble foreign policy of
clinton
and gore um and so the neocons saw the
writing on the wall that if you wanted
to keep
pursuing imperialism militarism the
democratic
party was going to be the place for that
and lo and behold in 2016 the
republicans nominated a candidate
who ran in opposition not just to the
iraq war but to regime change in syria
to questioning nato um to
you know accusing the cia of being
corrupt to telling generals they want
war so they can sit on the board of
raytheon sounding like noam chomsky in a
lot of
in a lot of ways um whatever his motives
might be
so all these militarists these
traditional
you know kind of neoliberal neocons are
coming back into power
and like we said before you know
whatever you want to say about trump he
did not initiate a new war though we
escalated obama campaigns
and i would be shocked if we get through
four years of a democratic
administration without at least a new
war
what about corporatism how is uh how is
joe biden the herald of
of corporatism
well i think it's more the democratic
party although biden in particular so
again just go back to what we know about
him
in the senate probably the most
consistent and important
policies he pursued while a senator was
defending banks and the credit card
industry because they're based in
delaware
which you know you can justify as
pragmatic or whatever but nonetheless
it's true
and so for example when the credit card
company was desperate to make it more
difficult for consumers to
discharge bad debt through bankruptcy it
was joe biden who led the way
in advocating for a bankruptcy bill that
did nothing but help
his corporate donors and bank donors
that was the thing that supposedly made
elizabeth warren
so angry about the corruption in both
parties that she entered politics and
ran for the senate
she cited that as the reason that bill
that joe biden sponsored
and if you look at who funds the
democratic party now
the the contributions from wall street
in silicon valley were overwhelmingly to
the democratic party they were when
hillary ran as well
they were when when obama first ran
against
uh john mccain in 2008 too they kind of
evened out because mitt romney obviously
is a creature of wall street they were
very happy with him but in general
the democrats are the party of the
professional managerial class
joe biden did not beat donald trump
because all these people of color and
women rose up in anger and the way
donald trump spoke of march that's all
[ __ ] that's media narrative lie
he won because all of these affluent
white professional managerial
suburbanites who have always voted
republican abandoned the republican
party and voted for democrats if
anything
trump ate into the the the the minority
vote that democrats have always
enjoyed despite spending four years
being called to racism white
supremacists and fascists and all that
that's the direction the democratic
party is headed
that was the choice they made under bill
clinton was to stop being affiliated
with unions
to do things like nafta welfare reform
and just to act they deregulated wall
street um it's
the party of larry summers um you know
not the party of bernie sanders and
they are in bed with silicon valley
they're in bed with corporate america at
the expense of
the workers who recognize that they've
abandoned them
you know i would argue uh as well that
uh joe biden is one of the great
architects of the drug war
uh you've written a lot about drug
legalization and
uh decriminalization in portugal and
elsewhere
um and i i uh raised biden's history of
pushing massive amounts of drug
regulation i mean he
uh various crime bills that uh
heightened drug penalties
uh the rave act he uh in the 80s he
helped create the office of the drugs
are things like that
i raise that not because he's a drug
warrior which he is but
is it possible though he is now talking
about
you know possibly having a federal uh
legalization of marijuana at the federal
level
partly because times have changed i mean
you know
has the country moved against war in a
way that it will overcome whatever the
military-industrial complex wants to do
has the country gotten sick of various
forms of crony capitalism in a way that
biden
will not be able to like he he won't
actually
play the script that he's been writing
or that he's written for the past 50
years
well let's remember first of all that
not only as you say it was biden the
author of things like the 1994 crime
bill
they probably did more for incarcerating
black people
in a year when that became front and
center processing
against that but he also choses his
running mate in kamala harris
a person who got out of law school and
chose to become a prosecutor to spend
her life
putting people in cages and she wasn't
just any prosecutor she's like a
hardcore
drug warrior law and order increasing
punishments for non-violent offenses
so if what you're asking me is have
certain things changed enough
that they're going to influence biden i
would say in one
very kind of relatively inconsequential
sense yes which is politicians do follow
the public
on culture war questions right so
there's no way for any democratic party
politician and most
with national aspirations to be against
marriage equality or trans rights or
increasingly
marijuana legalization because those are
things that corporate america doesn't
give the slightest [ __ ] about they don't
care if gays marry they don't care if
people
have abortions they don't care if
marijuana is legal or not so
they let politicians follow populist you
know opinion on those questions because
they're not really at the center of
power
but on the questions of what ours at the
center of power just look at what's
happening now
when trump is trying to withdraw troops
from afghanistan a country where we've
been fighting for 19 years the longest
war in american history
you see tammy duckworth giving speeches
saying
somehow bringing troops home is going to
result in them being in body bags
you know susan rice saying that accusing
trump of being precipitous i watched you
know three or four months ago
the house armed services committee
hearing where they approved the
750 billion dollar budget which is a
weird thing to do right if you think a
country is being led by a fascist to
increase
dramatically the military spending over
which he exercises discretion but that's
what the democratic
uh lead house did and in that hearing
there was an amendment
to bar the trump administration that
said we want to bring troops home
from afghanistan by the end of the year
the democrats on the house armed
services committee
led by adam smith who is a congressman
from washington whose biggest donors are
raytheon in general dynamics
um joined with liz chaney liz
cheney to block the kind of left right
anti-war coalition that arose up like
tulsi gabbard and
rokhan on the left and matt gates on the
right who was saying like
i think we should make america great
first before we make kandahar great
first
and they just steamrolled over them and
you see the same coalition now that's
who's gonna be in power no bill
crystal and david frum and the lincoln
project didn't support joe biden and
kamala harris
in order for them to stop pursuing
militarism nor did wall street and
silicon valley pour their money into
that campaign
in order for them to abandon the tenets
of corporatism they're going to be
much more answerable to their donors and
to the centers of power in the united
states than they will to popular opinion
that's always been how they function
um you know the third uh thing that you
pointed out
as a threat from a biden harris
administration is censorship
uh in what ways are you talking about
how will they be sensorial
well so we know for sure
that censorship is increasing on the
internet because of facebook and twitter
i think one of the most shocking things
i've seen as an american citizen in my
life
is that when i went to go post the new
york post story two weeks before an
election
this isn't some like website that got
created three months ago this is the
oldest newspaper in the united states
founded by alexander hamilton
you couldn't post it you couldn't even
send it as a dm twitter blocked it
like like it was china or iran like
they just said no this content cannot be
circulated
on the internet on our site which is
basically a monopoly
and when mark zuckerberg and jack dorsey
and the ceo of alphabet which is a
parent company of google
went before the senate to be questioned
ed markey who is a
massachusetts democrat who was just
reelected because the left
i mean the real left not liberals the
left got really behind him
they he was running against joe kennedy
iii
who was kind of a more moderate figure
and they destroyed him in the primary
and got behind ed markey and mark he
said to mark zuckerberg
our problem with you mr zuckerberg is
not that you're censoring too much our
problem is that you're not censoring
enough
and went on to show you know 10
different accounts that he thinks should
be removed from the internet that are on
the right
they are absolutely going to use their
their influence with with facebook and
and and google and twitter to pressure
those companies to censor the people
they regard as
dangerous not just on the right by the
way but also on the left the left a lot
of people on the left don't realize
this that the censorship they're urging
is going to be turned against them
but the other thing that's going to
happen that i think is more subtle but
more important
is that if you listen to what they're
saying they're talking about
they're not going to let go of this idea
that has been so beneficial to them
that there's this fascist movement in
the united states that we all have to
get behind the new york times and nbc
news and the cia and fbi
because they're the bull works against
fascism that is not going anywhere
that's going to stay that's going to be
the primary media narrative even with
trump gone
and so what they're going to be saying
is that if you are a
critic of the biden harris
administration from the right
you're not just an adversary you're a
domestic terrorist you're a
fascist white supremacist militia member
and that the powers of the state should
be used against you people forget
that after the oklahoma city bombing
when militias right-wing militias became
all the rage the media turned him into
this huge threat you know like
mostly white guys who dressed up in
fatigues in idaho and montana were
against federal occupation of
federal land after that happened they
used that
incident to say that the u.s government
should have
backdoor access to all internet
communications so there should be no
encryption that the government can't
access
that was the clinton administration was
very early on in the internet before
anyone even understood that
and there was republicans who opposed
that on privacy grounds and it didn't
get passed although it almost did
this is absolutely the what you know
they
the tactics that they use on the war on
terror which were infiltrating
you know five groups of 21 year olds who
are muslims
getting one of them with like emotional
problems or financial problems to sign
on to some plot that the fbi really
devised
that they never would have done on their
own and then announcing oh look we just
found this muslim terrorist plot and
scared everybody or they were going to
go bomb this or bomb that
that's what they're going to do to like
kids on meth in montana
or nebraska or whatever and they're
going to find these like
isolated rings of white supremacists
fascist
terrorists and they're going to msnbc
and the new york times is going to blow
it up into the and then the fbi and
and the attorney general uh is going to
say we need
very strong measures in the name of
domestic security
against these organizations and one of
them is going to be suppressing speech
that they're going to say is designed to
advance or forward the ideology of those
groups
uh you know this uh reminds me of a
final point or a conversation topic i
want to get to
i in in preparing for this i came across
an old cnn appearance of you with
jeffrey toobin who has
recently been fired from cnn and the new
yorker
arguing about bradley manning at the
time
and the release of the documents that
chelsea manning gave to wikileaks
and um you were arguing that
uh you know this was a good thing it was
beneficial for citizens to know what was
going on and the information that was in
there
whereas uh toobin was saying you know as
a journalist
that we should not have the right or we
should not have access to these sorts of
documents because
the government said that they were
secret do you see that
is that the dynamic that has really
become mainstream and you see going
forward
under a biden harris administration with
the news media
the way it is now
yeah i mean one of the things that
disturbs me the most um
hold on nick one second let me just get
this dog
sorry this is an old dog who's infirmed
he's going to bark no problem
um one of the things that really bothers
and disturbs me the most
is that as we were talking about earlier
the
intention of facebook and google and
twitter
and silicon valley in general from the
beginning was not to censor
they began to censor because journalists
demanded they do so
in part because journalists are
authoritarians who believe that
the uh modes of
information dissemination need to be
regulated by them and by others
um that's just unfortunately the modern
day mentality of the journalist it used
to be an anti-authoritarian mentality
and now they work
big corporations to become
authoritarians but also
um they don't believe in the
right of citizens to confront power
centers
they think that reporting means somebody
in power like in the cia
or the fbi gives you information
and then tells you to go repeat it to
the public
and then you go and do that and you
think they think that's reporting
but if somebody outside of the scope of
power like some low-level
army private like chelsea manning who
doesn't occupy an important position
in washington or edward snowden
does the same thing but not with the
intention of propagandizing but with the
intention of
illuminating they view that as criminal
journalists view the dissemination of
information about what powerful people
in the doc are doing in the dark not as
their
principal function and purpose which is
what it ought to be if we had a healthy
media
but it's something to be denounced and
condemned i mean i remember when i did
the snowden story
the people who had the way trying to
suggest that i ought to be
prosecuted not just edward snowden where
people like david gregory i meet the
press and andrew ross sorkin
on the cnn bc show the new york times
colonists and plenty of others
um it's an authoritarian mentality that
has contaminated journalism
and it manifests as being pro-censorship
and anti-transparency as shocking it as
it is
they are mouthpieces of the institutions
of power and not watchdogs over them
uh you know uh speaking of snowden um
do you think trump is seriously thinking
about pardoning edward snowden
and also let me bring up julian assange
uh who
has you know effectively been neutered
um
and you know underwent a kind of
psychological
uh trauma over the past several years
he's going to have some kind of
extradition hearing uh in january
what do you think the future holds for
whistleblowers um
you know under biden and harris
well the irony is we were talking
earlier about
how media figures have
petulantly whined about trivial acts on
the part of
trump like tweeting mean things about
wolf blitzer
and chuck todd and the reality is that
the only thing the trump administration
really has done that's genuinely
menacing to press freedom
is the prosecution and attempted
extradition of julian assange for
publishing not
information in connection with the 2016
election
but the 2010 uh
iraq and afghanistan war logs and
diplomatic cables that exposed war
crimes and other
acts of barbarism and savagery on the
part of the us and allied governments
because the theory that's being used to
prosecute assange
is one that would criminalize almost any
journalist um
in fact the theory used by the bolsonaro
government to try and
indict me earlier this year was very
similar to that theory and i think they
thought well if the us government is
doing this assange
we can do this to him and it will be
used against other journalists as well
um and you know i think that trump
remembers
several things he remembers that julian
assange
published information about hillary
clinton that helped him win
i think he realizes that
edward snowden risked his liberty and
has been in exile for seven years now
because he exposed the abusive nature of
spying powers
by the nsa and the cia and the fbi that
were used against the trump campaign
and then the trump administration
throughout 2016 and into 2017
and that the people who want julian
assange and edward snowden punished
john brennan and james clapper and susan
rice and mike hayden
are the same people who have worked
clandestinely and i think corruptly
to undermine the trump campaign and then
the trump administration
using and abusing the powers of the
state to do so
and the reason they want julian assange
to die in prison
and the reason they want edward snowden
to have to live out the rest of his life
in russia or be in prison as well
is obviously not because they regard
them as ongoing threats
but because they want to create a
climate where people who
discover illegal acts on the part of
powerful people
inside the government who want to expose
those acts the way snowden or manning
who was tortured
or assange have done think to themselves
wait if i do that i'm gonna have my life
destroyed
the way these people did the people who
prosecuted us snowden was the obama
administration the people who tortured
and prosecuted
chelsea manning was obama even though he
out of a humanitarian gesture after
seven years let her
go by commuting her sentence they chose
not to prosecute
assange even though they wanted to but
that was before the 2016 election
they now hate him even more and so i'm
sure they're going to continue
that prosecution as well so i'm very
worried about
what a biden terrorist administration is
going to do when it comes to leakers and
whistleblowers and sources except for
the ones
who are leaking to their approved
journalists for
reasons that are designed to advance
their interests
uh final question uh when you were
interviewed by reason in 2014 you
received our lanny friedlander prize
named after the founder
of reason for a variety of ways in which
you would increase the possibilities
of human expression and free expression
you talked a little bit or we discussed
a little bit about a libertarian
progressive
caucus or kind of coalition
do you think uh obviously your politics
and kind of reasons libertarian politics
overlap in certain
important ways and also are at
loggerheads uh
what do you think is is a libertarian
progressive coalition built around
things
like um pushing back on militarism
on state surveillance trying to uh
you know secure free speech in in many
ways is that going to be the place where
the pushback the resistance to biden
harris and whatever comes next going to
be coming from
yeah you know well this is the
interesting thing you know i think
when we were talking in 2014 when i used
to do work with cato with reason
you know the areas of left libertarian
convergence were pretty clear they were
things like opposition to the drug war
distrust of institutions of authority in
the national security state though not
in the financial realm which is one of
the reasons
the left in libertarians diverge um
defense of free speech things of that
nature
so i think libertarians on the left
still have those things in common those
things are incredibly important still so
i think the left libertarian alliance
you know as as we defined it then is is
pretty much unchanged
except that those issues are more
important what i think has happened
though
is that there's a whole other group of
people who
never used to identify with those issues
who have now migrated to them
whether they're like you call them right
wing populists
you know you can find it for example in
tucker carlson
um in a lot of the right-wing populism
that trump tried to tap into
so it was always kind of like before the
libertarians who have this common ground
with the left were the kind of
libertarians like you guys that never i
found a comfort or a home in either
political party
now actual republicans conservatives
trump supporters
people on fox news are realizing that
these
issues of repressive behavior
not just by things like facebook and
google and twitter which they're
obviously opposed to
but also the national security state and
the cia they've seen how this is abused
they
they feel victimized by it personally
they call it the deep state
they know what these these institutions
are capable of they don't trust them any
longer the way they did during the war
on terror
and i think that is causing a
realignment now where you have
as i said before this new coalition that
i kind of would
describe as the democratic party the cia
the nsa and fbi bush cheney operatives
neocon silicon valley and wall street
and then kind of everybody else who is
very wary of
the extraordinary power and the
authoritarian mentality
that coalition has coalesced around
and so i think this opportunity for that
kind of an alliance that you described
is
much greater because there's a lot more
people than just leftists like me and
libertarians like you
who are starting to realize that the big
issues to care about aren't abortion and
gay rights
or tax cuts for the wealthy or
opposition to iran or support for israel
they're
the ability to be free as citizens of
this incredibly
repressive institutional power that is
growing by the day
all right well we're going to leave it
there we've been talking with glenn
greenwald who is currently
uh starring at sub stack.com until they
kick him off
so glenn thanks so much for talking with
reason